yeah I welcome you to this video playing
devo and I hope they're playing a little
bit better than they came before because
it wasn't one of the booths blitz games
ever I really i just got check made it
almost out of nothing but put it we did
I mean nothing I mean I played played
terribly would like and against an
opponent that I have played before and
is not well I was a pretty clean victory
in person first game so anyway so let's
see debo clicks III to cover I think
will be six first is better now oh yeah
I should have played should be six first
this is looking whiskey very risky
actually
okay so what's going on d 6 i'm totally
castle first and i have to play the six
and then attack the center the air
probably this is the only square I
wonder if six is a good move or not this
whole position is a bit shaky okay it's
difficult and this is what you want to
want to get here with this a
non-symmetrical opening want some kind
of imbalance and sometimes the imbalance
is just that you're worth so let's see
what happens okay I'm attacking me five
now and the bishop so I can win this
pause maybe development is not exactly
great so it's not just the pawn pawn web
okay if you give me more I mean I'm
taking them very likely I have to return
some of the material d 6 foot Bishop to
g5 ok I will cover that d 6 a heavy six
also I just spotted that so I'm what
what about Phineas 35
coupons now I'll take widest cultivation
got a week square on c6 you want the
bishop than something that night if FOIA
okay this is not a big deal
[Music]
message it why I'm just too warmed up
for nothing ok looks is six and nights
of 4k not before a queen GP aid small
application I think keeping the e5 pawn
and ready to advance ya hear I mean I
wonder he six he might take this
probably just grabbing his right and now
be sure to a six I don't see a drawback
should take Luke shakes I'm immediately
attacking the knight and if i get to get
go a 3 i'm in the a porn with the the
bishop being on g7 it's very dangerously
so ok and yet i can take on f1 just now
here but we should be fired right it
looks nice all those campaign unhook t8n
equate square for the Queen no Stan said
I was thinking just a 4 here at a 3s rea
three Emmys but he might take on before
you look a form it's not super
convincing so if i go bishop here
mailing look at the night and prepare a
three
yeah night second really does not work
but maybe he feels that other stuff
doesn't do it either okay okay some cool
something to e7 awesome let's go here
[Music]
yeah maybe we create I just to see the
booty on C file also opened can also do
this actually next week ok clean f6
maybe I can still do clean f6 my loop is
hanging you know I didn't see that more
I'm really awfully awfully back to
fender I attend to get just extremely
nervous in those situations and play
complete non subject at that times even
against the texts that are completely
like completely incorrect like this one
[Music]
time learning
you should can take actually no cannot
take a can place winner takes teeth
ok mr. made or something ok check check
check like forfeit on time I think he's
running out of a chick sense I am
terribly bad at playing those solutions
really terribly bad or if you like I can
miss something whatever ok I think I
made a mistake in the opening I should
just go back to be six I think this is
right so that a four is a bit less
interesting but ok so we have this a
form before and the engine doesn't mind
my position I wasn't sure it looks a
little bit loose Jim I felt there might
be something for white but the computer
does not show on something instantly and
I know I think there is probably nothing
ya hear I feel like I should be fine the
computer sig is white some compensation
we're not anyone
yeah I prayed it quite well up to the to
the very to this position which was
completely winning and then that that is
stuck is completely incorrect but I
still get into trouble because I'm
getting nervous whatever I didn't even
see that this was hanging on h6 you know
this is completely unnecessary I give
him that power okay and by now things
are not clear as we CL engine is not
giving they're giving much or 24 wins we
are not surprised I mean I keep
blundering away those positions and I
didn't see it and ultimately I want them
now then I'm really bad with those will
be the king someone opened and there are
many checks and so on and playing stuff
that is really totally totally bad okay
thanks for watching